stop stop stop you're going to take some
of iron besides you're saying it wrong
it's Leviosa not live you saw what's
going on guys this is rob you all crack
me up with your whole nomenclature like
word pronunciation thing like I saw so
many comments like it's submariner rob
it's not Sabrina you're saying it wrong
I love you guys for that that's that's
one of the reasons i love you guys so
much you guys are so opinionated you
guys are are so just like it has to be
said the right way just it just has to
be that way you know and it's just kind
of funny honestly I've always said
submariner I've always said Namor the
Submariner this always been that way
ever since I was like a little kid ever
since I read about name of some readers
it's always been Namor the Submariner so
in the future I'll try to correct that
i'll try to say Namor the Submariner but
you know it's just it's one of those
ingrained habits just one of those
things it's just kind of a kind of stuck
in me I don't know why it is the way it
is but it's just like that but if it
bothers you guys that much then you know
I'll go ahead and try to get it
corrected a few other things um I did
that video with like five o'clock in the
morning so i was really tired you know i
was i tried to repeat it and i try to
you know like make it better it was just
really kind of tough to do it was just
kind of like all right you know i mean
i'd done it like three or four times
before that point I was kind of like
okay you know I hate to do this but
we're just going to go ahead and throw
it out there and see how it goes and and
for the most part like it contained you
know the information that was necessary
although beat it really wasn't up to
like my standard per se which I think
you guys have really kind of got an idea
of where I like to have my content at
but you know sometimes you just got to
kind of cut your losses and I hate to
put it that way but you know it's it's
you know I wanted to make sure that that
videos were going to you guys we were
able to knock these things out because
you know if it was egregious if it was
like well you know we see that Wolverine
dies and he gets his head chopped off
you know and I was just going on about
nonsense well of course I wouldn't I
wouldn't do that but I think you know it
wasn't it wasn't really that big
I don't think you guys would hear that
much but it seems like you guys were
more concerned about the fact that I was
pronouncing name or the submariners name
wrong as opposed to anything else in the
video one of the other things is yes I'm
aware that I threw in Captain America
when I shouldn't have you know it's then
they was that big of a deal but you know
again you guys are really kind of
opinionated in that in that way and
that's not a bad thing you know I don't
think it's a bad thing when subscribers
really kind of speak up and say like you
said this wrong because as you guys know
I like to maintain a certain standard
widow of like quality with my videos you
know I want my videos to be of the
highest caliber that I can make them and
you guys contribute to that so so don't
think that if I see a comment that says
you mispronounced this or you said
captain america when you should have
said Iron Man or something like that
that's fine i mean i'm not going to get
mad at you guys i'm not going to get be
upset i'm not going to be disheartened
or anything like that you know i know
negative criticism what i see it not no
positive criticism when i see it so i
know how to take things you know as they
are and really kind of a move forward
with him but um yeah so we have I think
two more colleagues until we're finished
now there were some comics that I didn't
include I know you guys really kind of
wanted to see him but there were some
comics that I didn't include because for
the most part they really have nothing
to do with a civil war story and I for
the life of me don't really even know
why they're included like the runaways
the runaways really has nothing to do
with a civil war story I mean it kind of
shows us that there are other groups
being affected but I think for the most
part we've established the rift between
the superhero community with a civil war
front line and what heroes for hire and
so all we would really be doing is
including those comics for the sake of
including them as opposed to really kind
of giving you guys an idea of what civil
war is really about and I think that
when we're doing these kind of series
when we're doing these kind of like
stories it's important that you guys get
the details it's important that you guys
are made aware of what's going on and
you guys kind of get the story in its
entirety but if I say a and then I say B
and then I say be a second time just for
the sake of it it doesn't really do
anything it doesn't really help anything
and so after get I go ahead and leave
though
plus the runaways really just weren't
that interesting you know me I'll do a
video on him I think you know a few you
guys want to see me do a video on the
runaways and we'll do that you know at a
future time but you know for right now I
figure if we're going to do the Civil
War and we're going to try to you know
include these tie-ins we're going to try
to do it in the most economic way
possible and we're going to try to do it
in a way that can maintain your
interests that can maintain my interest
and then it really won't make the series
drag on and on and on and on and on
because that really kind of gets silly I
know a lot of you guys really want to
see House of M house of them is a series
that we will do what we will do House of
M when when many finishes doing Avengers
disassembled because the Avengers
disassembled leads directly into the
house of them like the events that take
place and Avengers disassembled go
directly into the house of him because
both events revolve around the Scarlet
Witch so we will do that series it's
just going to take a little bit of time
you know when Vinny gets done with all
his stuff then we'll go ahead and and
get that series updated speaking of
Benny Benny is doing a guardians of the
galaxy month so if you guys are really
interested in learning more about the
guardians of the galaxy besides the
video that I had made I guess a few
months ago the new guys are welcome to
go over there in fact i would highly
suggest you go over there and watch his
videos about guardians of the galaxy
he's going to give you some in-depth
stuff about star-lord he's going to give
you some in-depth stuff about rocker
McCune and Gomorrah and how the team
actually came together and he might even
tie into the annihilation storyline I'm
not one hundred percent sure what
direction he's going there but I do know
that he is doing a guardians of the
galaxy month as a build-up to the
guardians of the galaxy coming out on
august first yeah aside from that
there's really isn't a whole lot in
terms of updates we're almost finished
with the the Civil War event as a whole
will have the next video uploaded
probably on Thursday I think I wanted to
go ahead and take a break for wednesday
I have a computer Destin I need to put
together and I've got some wires I ate
around and stuff like that but um on
Thursday will have the final tie-in for
civil war issue number four finished and
then the following Monday will upload
Civil War issue number five and then you
know continue the process of doing the
tie-in videos for Civil War II issue
number five after that it's smooth
sailing we've got like Civil War issue
number six I think they're sometimes
between civil war issue number five and
six about as many as we saw with civil
war issue number four but i'll go ahead
and try to
maybe release a few videos in one day so
that we can really kind of speed up the
the end of Civil War but after Civil War
issue number six we've got you know
maybe I don't know four or five comics
and then we've got the ending we've got
Civil War issue number seven and I
really think you guys are going to enjoy
the direction that civil war is going
and I think you guys are really going to
like the way that things really kind of
come to a head although some of you may
find an ending to be a little lackluster
it really kind of depends on what you
like in comic books and of course at the
very end of all this will touch into the
major of interworld will do a video
about the major event that involves
Captain America now the other thing that
I really want to talk to you guys about
is what I'm thinking about is when civil
war comes to an end when we're finished
with the Civil War video I'm thinking
about doing maybe some kind of like
roundtable discussion and it won't be
won't include many a one include day or
anything like that it'll just be you
guys in me so if any of you guys have a
skype account if any of you guys want to
want to chat with me on skype and send
me a message and I'll go through and
i'll pick a few people and i'll take
maybe about three of you guys and so the
four of us will sit down and we'll
basically kind of have this roundtable
skype chat or we'll talk about civil war
make sure you guys have a webcam make
sure you have a decent quality
microphone a blue snowball or better I'd
really kind of hate to have you guys you
know with the webcam that's really
choppy and grainy and a microphone with
the audio is really difficult to
understand but but yeah let me know you
know let me know if you guys are
interested in that kind of thing you
know I really like the idea of us really
kind of sitting down and talking about
civil war we can talk about what we
thought the best parts of Civil War were
we can talk about the things we didn't
like that much we can kind of debate the
morality of Civil War you know what is
right and what is wrong is the stands to
Tony Stark took was it right was it
wrong we could really kind of go from
there and I think we can have a really
cool discussion but of course that'll be
after the Civil War event is over but
yes I'd from out there really isn't too
much so the next video will be up on
Thursday Civil War issue number five
will be up the following Monday and then
we'll continue the trend of uploading
videos between for the times between
civil war issue number five and six and
then we'll be done so I'd say probably
within the next three weeks we'll be
finished with a civil war event so so ya
might even be two weeks 900 sent sure
yet but in any event um yeah so I'm
gonna go and bring this video to an end
hope you guys enjoyed it and thanks for
watching